okay I've got a great series of clips
for you from fox news here Tucker
Carlson who as I mentioned has said that
white supremacy is a hoax said that
immigrants make our country dirtier
he also said he believes Michelle Obama
is someone that could get into the 2020
Democratic primary race and maybe
actually win so Fox News host Bill
Hemmer brought on a guy named Michael
Blake Michael Blake is the vice chair of
the DNC he's also a New York state
assemblyman and Michael Blake
immediately went in on Tucker Carlson
and also on Fox News this is this is
just brilliant execution he was asked by
Bill Hemmer
is Tucker's prediction right might
Michelle Obama be about to get into this
race and Michael Blake goes full in on
wise Tucker still on this network he
said white supremacy is a host Bill
Hemmer
is a hoax Bill Hemmer immediately tries
to shut it down we know that Fox didn't
like it when Shep Smith criticized
Tucker Carlson Tucker must be protected
and this is just a pleasure to watch
hello Bhama let's be honest is one of
the only people who could unite the
parties warring factions Tucker Carlson
with a bold prediction saying Michelle
Obama just may be the Democratic ticket
next year despite the former first lady
saying she's not interested Michael
Blake vice chair of the DNC in a New
York State Assemblyman how you doing
Mike nice to see you sir would the
prediction on Michelle Obama I'd like to
see that
well she's not running but the core
question is why the hell does tuck a car
still have a job here in the first place
the reality is this is someone who said
white supremacy is a hoax
and why does fox allow him to still be
here in the first place well I mean his
opinion there is that Michelle Obama may
get in this race do you think that will
happen or is nothing not going to happen
on it not going to happen but I think
the the core question is he shouldn't be
on here at all yeah we didn't bring you
on to talk about Tucker Carlson I
brought you on to talk about the
Democratic field
I love how Bill Hemmer says you aren't
on here to talk about Tucker he kind of
is you played a clip of Tucker and then
said please respond to what Tucker said
this continued and Bill Hemmer getting
even more visibly angry about all of
this we're talking about jobs while
Trump is ignoring the truth we're
talking about health
while he's ignoring the truth and the
question must be for Donald Trump for
Fox News for other entities listen I -
our network so with all due respect why
don't we just keep it on topic but it's
not political magazine says this just
out no it's not well the Christmas it is
not relevant to the conversation we're
having I just I really relish how
furious Bill Hemmer is getting maybe
because he could get in trouble for
allowing a guest to do this is that a
possibility here really well done by
Michael Blake I would be shocked if he's
invited back on Fox News one thing that
you don't you know there's this is an
interesting thing there's this unspoken
understanding between Fox News and
left-wing guests Democratic guests
progressive guests which is you can
criticize the right in your role as the
lefty that we're inviting on to give an
opinion but you're not supposed to go
after Fox News the few times that a
guest has really done it it's not
welcomed it's it's quite the opposite in
fact
and Michael Blake ignored that unspoken
rule and just did it good for him
absolutely love it I'd be shocked if we
ever see him on Fox News again today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman if you've not already
heard about blink Asst it's amazing it's
an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a fifteen minute
audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
caen
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa K ma n